- [Instructor] What we are
going to do in this video
is talk a little bit about
experiments in science
and experiments are really the heart
of all scientific progress.
If you think about,
let's just say this represents
just baseline knowledge
and then people have hunches in the world
and for a lot of times people say, hey,
I have a hunch that that
thing is good for you
or that thing is good for you
but they really had no way of measuring
how confident they were.
They really had no good way of proving it
and even more, because they
had no good way of proving it,
it was hard for people to
build on top of that knowledge
but with the scientific
method and experiments,
people were able to say, hey,
we have a hypothesis here
and we were able to do some
well-designed experiments
and so we feel pretty
good that this is true
and then future people are going to say,
hey, since we feel pretty
good that this is true,
maybe we can design experiment
to see whether that is true.
Hey, that actually is true and
then they can build on that
and we end up having scientific progress
that can accumulate over hundreds of years
and this is really important
that the experiments are well-designed
because in the future and
this happens all the time,
we might realize that hey,
actually there was a little,
a few assumptions baked in
here that weren't accurate
that allowed us to make
essentially misleading conclusions.
So our conclusion wasn't quite right there
and then we will have to
rebuild from that point
in order to make sure that
we are truly making progress.
So the key question is
how do we set up well-designed experiments
and it's a whole field of study
but the whole purpose of this video
is to really give an introduction to it.
So let's just start with a hypothesis.
Let's say that you have a hypothesis
that some pill that is made up
of the petals of some flower,
that this pill right
over here, it improves,
it improves running, running speed.
It improves running speed
if someone were to take it.
So the important thing of any hypothesis,
it has to be testable
and so what you do is you have to think
well, how am I going to test it?
Well, what you can do,
so how are you going to
test your hypothesis?
At first, you might say, give the pill,
so give the pill to some runners,
to some runners and test their time,
test their 100 meter time,
test their 100 meter time before the pill,
before the pill and after
and you might say, hey,
maybe if, I don't know,
their times improve after,
maybe my hypothesis is correct.
Pause this video and see
if you feel comfortable
with this test right over
here, this experiment.
Well, actually, there's several problems
with this experiment.
How are you selecting these runners
and if you give them the pill
and their speed improves,
did it truly improve because of the pill
or did it improve because
of some other thing
that they are doing?
Maybe they got new shoes
or maybe their diet improved in some way
or maybe they just had a
psychological improvement.
This is often known as the placebo effect.
If people are taking something
that they think will help
them, it often will help them
even if that thing is
just an empty capsule
or just a sugar tablet.
So how do you avoid these types of errors?
Well, what you could do
is you can find runners
and put them into two groups.
So let's say this is one
group right over here
and then this is another group
and what you would wanna do
is you'd wanna go into
the population of people
and you would want to randomly select
whether someone goes into
one group or another group.
Why random?
Because if you don't randomly select,
there's a chance that there
might be some implicit bias
that you might just happen
to be picking people
who maybe their running speed
is on an upward trajectory
and they just happen to go into the group
that will eventually get the pill.
So you randomly, randomly
put them in those groups
and what you wanna do is
you'll have a control group
and you'll have a group
that gets your pill
and so this group gets
the pill, gets the pill
and now you might be tempted
for this group to say,
oh, they don't get a pill and
then after a few months of it
and it should be the same amount of time,
you say, hey, did this
group's times improve
over the 100 meters?
How did that compare to this group?
But be very careful.
If this group gets the pill
and this group gets nothing
then the pill might be providing
that placebo effect again
just making people think
they're getting something
that's making 'em faster.
It might actually be a
self-fulfilling prophecy.
So it's actually important
that you also give these people a pill
although this pill would
just look like a pill
so this would be just an
empty, empty, empty pill
that looks the same.
Now, there's another idea
when you're designing
scientific experiments
that it needs to be double blind.
Let me write this down.
Double blind.
So as you could imagine,
it implies that two things are blind here.
So the first thing that needs to be blind
is the people themselves
should not know which group
they're getting put into.
They should not know
which pill they are taking
because obviously, if you
put someone in this pill,
in this group and you say, hey,
you're in the control group,
we're just gonna give you an empty pill,
well, then the placebo
effect might not be,
it might not work.
It's also important
'cause it's double blind
that the people who are
working with the runners,
the people who are measuring them
so that the researcher is right over here
so I'll draw someone with a clipboard.
So the researchers who
are observing these people
and maybe administering the pill
and telling them about the experiment
that they too do not know
which group they are administering it to
because if they did, they might
be able to signal somehow.
They might be able to even subconsciously
give a sense of which group folks are in
and so let's say we do all of these things
and so we're getting in the direction
of a well-designed experiment
and we find that the
10 people in this group
versus the 10 people in this
group after three months,
these folks had a 5%
improvement in running speed
and these people had a 10%
improvement in running speed.
Is that enough to conclude
that our hypothesis is correct?
Well, you might be tempted,
it seems suggestive
but that's where
statistics come into order
because there's just some random
chance that you got lucky,
that you happened to pick the people that,
your pill does nothing
but you just happened to pick the people
who are going to improve more
and there's a whole field
of inferential statistics
when you take a statistics course
that will go in more depth into this
but essentially, what you're
gonna do is you're gonna say,
hey, assume that your pill does nothing,
what's the probability of
getting this result for 10 people
or what's the probability
of getting this difference in result
and if that probability is very low,
well, you say, hey, that would suggest
that my pill actually does do something.
Now, another important principle
of an experiment like this
is it needs to be replicable, replicable
because even though you
thought you did a good job,
people might not wanna
take your word for it
and it's important in science
for people to be skeptical.
When people do experiments,
they want to have a result
and that bias might creep in
and so if someone else does an experiment,
you need to say how
you did that experiment
so other people can see if
they get the same results
because even though you
think you randomly selected,
you might only do it with
people from a certain country
or under certain weather conditions
or assuming other constraints
and then these people might
do it slightly differently
or in a different country or
under different constraints
and realize that hey,
the explanation for this
maybe was something else.
Another thing to keep in mind
is the larger your
samples right over here,
the larger groups that
you're able to do this with,
the stronger that the
statistics actually become
and I would say not just larger
but the more diverse across genders,
across ethnicities, across geographies.
So the big picture here
is all scientific progress
is based on us designing good experiments
and being very rigorous
about how we think about those experiments
and what I've highlighted
here is just the beginning
of how we might think about
designing those experiments
and as you go into your
scientific careers,
look at other people's experiments
and see whether they've done these things
because many times you will find
that it is not as rigorous
as it might seem at first.